all right this episode is brought to you
by gray block pizza as well this episode
is brought to you by zipper recruiter
zip recruiter it is everything you need
for business needs are you hiring
someone do not have someone well guess
what
zip recruiter is a better way to find
that missing person it's something
better than just posting your job online
and just praying for the right people to
see it you can't be praying about stuff
online that's not real so guess what
zip recruiter knew there was a smarter
way so they built a platform and it
finds the right job candidates for you
zip recruiter learns what you're looking
for identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job 80% of employers who post a job
on zip recruiter you get a quality can
adopt through the site in just one day
guess how long that is tomorrow
and right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free that's right for free
how much nothing go to zip recruiter
comm slash tpw that's zip recruiter comm
slash t pw zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire I will be in Tampa Florida
April 6th and 7th I just want to let you
guys know that you can come out and see
me I also have other dates coming up in
Hasbrouck Heights New Jersey at bananas
comedy club and at Cherokee Casino and
some other places but I'll put those on
the calendar coming shortly to you as
well you need to know about star flow
star flow it's the location for fans
trying to link up and get closer to the
favorite the celebrities star flow is a
safer ecosystem where your information
won't be sold on that dirty black market
star flow provides a hub for consumers
to access their favorite talents and
celebrities and exclusive content in
seconds it's available in the app store
at star flow calm or at star flow calm
it just stays out of that sell your
information a secondary market it's a
safe place where you and celebrities can
get together and not worry about being
judged for words you're using or or
things you want to research or it's just
as pure
it's the way it's supposed to be without
all these big dogs getting involved and
scratching at your B hole go to star
flow comm and check it out the link will
be in the information and now
[Music]
there you go
that's Jameson flood right there and
that gentleman named Jameson flood and
I'm not sure where he's from but that is
his music right there that song called
every night and thank you guys for being
here today welcome to this past weekend
you know I I almost cut the lights off
in the studio tonight you know cause
it's you know I'm making this it's night
time and this gonna be ready for you
guys in a few hours but almost cut the
lights off man cuz some of them I like
feeling that romance boy and the funny
thing is I noticed even if I cut the
lights off even if I'm by myself
I can feel a like a little bit of
romance you know I can feel like a
little bit of romance kind of come just
kind of just just tickling my tits a
little you know like I just like you try
this man if you put on put a shawl
around your neck you know put like a
soft cloth around your neck or even if
you can't afford a soft cloth or a shawl
or a you know a scarf nothing heavy
don't get one of those heavy ass scarfs
you know don't show up in a heavy yeah
you look like an idiot I'd go to soft
scarfs before I go one heavy scarf you
know one heavy scarf that's some amistad
type [ __ ] you know those days are over
okay go go to soft scarfs and give us
free but I love uh but if you put on and
if you don't have a scarf get you some
paper towels get you a like about nine
paper towels or eight people eight paper
towels in a row
okay take your shirt off you know take
your shirt off if you are a man or a
woman take your shirt off all right it
doesn't matter you know some people have
chest some people have tits you know
tits is just fat chest that's all that
is you know and and chest is just ah
lean tits that's
this you know and some people have
either one you know my mother had their
makeups than baby A's and so I didn't
see a lot of tit around the house even
if you know even if sometimes you know
sometimes when you're growing up if
you're a child and your mother have nice
breasts you get that free that free
visual you know you get that oh okay you
know even though it's your mother you
you know you're not being like that
but you still get that hit but my mother
had two makeups you know so it was more
you know it wasn't as I didn't get those
voluptuous visuals around the house but
what I'm saying is this you know is that
romance can be achieved even by oneself
everybody thinking oh I got to have
somebody to be romantic you know I got
to meet somebody on the internet and you
know and meet up with them somewhere you
know in a parking lot or something to be
romantic well that's [ __ ] those are
the old days you know nowadays here's
something you can do around your house
even if you're alone cut the lights down
put a few candles around your house
don't put a bunch of candles okay
especially if you don't use candles a
lot because you're somebody that's gonna
probably burn to death so just use a
couple of candles you know put them
around and then get you them um if you
put on a law a soft scarf or even two
really soft scarfs or get you a long
string of paper towels put that around
your neck and now just kind of glide
around your house a little bit make sure
the children are asleep or whatever you
know put a couple candles and just kind
of like you know lean against a wall
somewhere and be like Oh fancy seeing
you here
you know or open the refrigerator and
just take a hit off that coolness feel
that you know feel that cold air just
[ __ ] tickle your titty ends you know
you can make romance wherever you want
just be like Oh what was that in the
distance even if it was nothing even if
it was just a puppy over there touching
his little dick or something with his
paw or scratching himself
you know I'm saying you can make romance
wherever everybody acts like we got to
do this or got to do that to make
romance but you can make your own
romance and that's something that I'm
starting to realize in my life that just
because maybe if I don't have love in my
life at some point it doesn't mean that
I can't create romance in my life you
could do something nice for yourself get
you a couple of them uh you know
Valentine's is over they got a good deal
on chocolates out there go get out there
and get a 40 pack of chocolates man and
you can get those have you two or three
give some to a neighbor
now suddenly you eaten chocolates with
someone you know you can make your own
romance and I'm not saying that I'm not
trying to get people to be alone I don't
want people to be alone you know we got
this world right now that's just pushing
us to be alone they just advertising
everything you know do you do you do you
everybody doing themselves in this and
then you you got no friends you got no
friend you don't have anybody to borrow
a shirt from or anybody to borrow some
sugar from but if you happen to be by
yourself that doesn't mean that you
can't have a little bit of romance in
your life you know I do different things
sometimes I'll put my pants in the dryer
and then put them on my legs what is
that
ooh daddy got them hot sticks hanging
off his hips now you can treat yourself
to different things you can do different
things for yourself to get that romance
and this is the time of year to do it
you know because spring is in the air
they got that love they got that nest
you know if you get outside or earlier
something you hear birds in the distance
you know to [ __ ] or even just you
know petting each other heavily you know
you'll hear baby birds out there waiting
for that worm you know you could see
even some hookers are out there even
hookers are happy in the spring you ever
notice that you get a wintertime hooker
I'm saying you get that December escort
that lady ain't fired up she ain't
excited about the
seneschal [ __ ] money that could be
headed her way but you get out here you
know you know you get out here at these
times and and and ladies are fired up
you know if they're working out on the
streets even ladies are fired up as it's
springtime and love is in the air ah but
I'm trying to create some romance for
myself you know I'm trying to create
some romance because we have to do it
you know you go through times your life
where you know I feel you go through
times you know life where you don't have
that love were you getting to bed at
night and you just kick your legs out
across the other side of the bed and
there's nobody there
you know it's just you just swimming out
there like like that Nirvana baby and
that album cover you just swimming out
there you know and you want somebody you
want to have that other say you know you
want to have a little bit of love in
your life but they but that doesn't mean
you can't be romantic you know you could
still do romance a little bit and that's
one thing I would do from time to time
is I would you know wear something kind
of sexy even for a man you know
everybody acts like only women can have
sexy clothing or do something sexy but a
man can wear sexy stuff you know you
could wear some really large pants or
something you know you could um you know
I remember sometimes I would take you
know my grandmother whenever she died
they gave us some of her stuff and she
didn't have much you know she had a
strong strong ceramic reptile collection
and then she had what else does she have
she had a lot of she had saved a lot of
baked goods from over the years but in
the box still you know she had like
German chocolate cake from like 1974 you
know the recipe box so we had a couple
of you know exotic old cakes and stuff
you know unmade cakes in the packaging
but she had these kind of naughty shirts
I thought blouses they call them blouses
and that to me they look like just just
[ __ ] naughty curtains just hanging
off an old lady's neck you know
and so when my grandma passed I remember
I was young I was just coming in a you
know / Bertie and everything and I was
just rocking in a you know / Bertie
that's when your dick will wake you up
you don't even need an alarm clock your
dick will wake you up because it wants
to hound around and look for some coops
you know or fire off at some cat and I
noticed that I noticed that uh you know
I got that I got a you know I got about
a about a quarter box of them blouses
because we had for my grandmother for
grandchildren so everybody got it you
know a quarter of the items in this box
because some Senior Center she was at
sent us a box of her you know goods you
know death Goods or whatever because she
passed and so I got a quarter box of
these blouses a lot of baby blue and I
mean mint green but this barely any
green in it like you had to look deep
into that blouse to even just just catch
that hint of green it wasn't really a
mint I thought it was kind of like a
kind of like a summer lime but I
remember I'd put those blouses on dude
and and you know it honestly touched
myself and I know that's crazy but at
the time in my life you know when I was
coming into my own really that I felt
exotic you know it made me feel it was
sexual you know it was sexual and I
remember I'd catch some real strong ends
that means nuts honestly in the
springtime because your body's vibrant
you know and that's where we are right
now your body is people's bodies are
vibrant you know you'll see a woman just
drop a batch of eggs in the park right
now it's that time of year you know
people are fertile you know you'll see a
you know you'll see a God you know
jerking off into some begonias or
something I mean nature is looking for
each other you know you'll see a dam
you'll see a couple tulips and the park
blower dude a big tulip don't be
surprised I'm just saying that love is
in the air and that if you don't have
somebody if you don't have another
person at this moment that doesn't mean
that you can't treat yourself in ways to
feel loved that's what I'm feeling
because you know what I'm sick of look
I'm sick of letting these lonely bugs
live inside of my body for free you know
I'm sick of walking around thinking oh I
don't have I don't have you know I don't
have nobody to hold my heart at night
you know I don't or I don't have anybody
to share a toothbrush with or I don't
have a good person to you know pull
their hair out of the drain when I use
my shower you know I don't have those
love rituals in my life but you can have
them you know when you have to some of
those you might have to create by
yourself in the mean time but you can do
fun stuff for yourself you know put some
[ __ ] honey on your thighs you know
put some tzatziki on your [ __ ] hip
bones do something for yourself because
you don't have to have another person to
have romance but I remember yeah man I
would get shirtless and I would put that
long string of paper towels around my
old neck and I would just kind of peruse
around the house in the dark you know
with those candles lit just waiting for
a big beautiful lady just to come and
just you know just just blow me out so
you have to sometimes create romance for
yourself but I want to thank you guys
for being here with me you know we had
such a great response last week on the
podcast and it's inspiring
I want to thank ray block pizza that's
our charter sponsor I could not I could
not have even started this podcast or
really kept it going I don't think if at
some point somebody didn't say hey I
want to help and I'm grateful to them
great block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard
in Los Angeles if you're driving around
you ain't got nothing to do you got 40
minutes to kill go to grey block open
your mouth
give them a couple books they give you
some Italian get that what else is going
on man we had some wild calls that came
in you know last week I know things got
a little bit you know we got heavy man
we'll keep it all look you know in this
podcast it goes where it goes
it goes where it goes supposed to have
my first guess
this week do I want to tell you all who
it is do I not want to tell you I don't
know see I'm coming this I'm still a
little bit nervous in this scenario but
I don't want to tell you cuz I don't
want to get people's hopes up but also
sometimes I want to put it out into the
air because you know I want my guests to
want to come on I guess you know I get
nervous about having guests because I
get nervous sometimes to ask people to
do stuff for me or to do stuff with me
you know I have um I don't know all my
life I've felt like that you know if I
ask somebody to do something or ask
somebody to do something even that's
awesome you know even ask somebody to
come spend some time that they're gonna
you know I guess maybe that they're
gonna say no because they think that
something's wrong that um I guess the
fear is that I'm not good enough you
know that they're gonna be like ah ah
you know uh you know your you know your
little podcast or spending time with you
isn't and that's a Hollywood thing you
know it's just a Hollywood thing that
sometimes but that's what keeps me
sometimes from asking certain you know
gasps and I'm trying to just you know
get friends that I can be comfortable
with and be comfortable around so but
thank you guys for holding on your
patience in there we got the chairs in
we have everything we got a guy coming
tomorrow to hook up some cameras and get
it right but we had this call coming man
we're gonna roll through some calls are
gonna fit right into the show I'm
getting more comfortable with making
things flow and and yeah make you treat
yourself well you know you're not oh
you're not lonely you might be alone but
you're not lonely you know and there's
ways to get through it we got this let's
take this hitter right here here we go
oh that's a song here we go
let's take this hold on man damn boy
some white guy hold on
all right we got this dude here we go
hold on boy I'm living brother homeward
say I want to ask you a question have
you ever done one of those hot springs
on those hot spring bath there was an
Glenwood Colorado and I did one of those
hot spring bath I have all the minerals
and everything in it Oh a hot spring
bath man yeah I mean I have I done
something I have I have done well I have
done some I was here a little more well
if you paid $24 for a bath man I don't
know if we know each other you know cuz
you at them hopper you taking them
high-priced dips you know I'm not the
kind of guy will spend $24 on a bath
have I been assume Hot Springs yes man I
was in I actually as a student we took a
trip one time into um I did work study
on a cruise ship and we took we took a
trip over to Japan and we walked off in
a Kyoto out into the hills and stuff
like that you know and that's [ __ ] I
mean that's you could buy some exotic
swords out there when you get far enough
out of those Japanese hillsides it's
like damn Zelda you know you could reach
into a bush and pull out a [ __ ] you
know you know an electric vaz and change
it and trade it in you know nine minutes
later under a bridge for a couple of
exotic swords and we were out there in
the countryside what little countryside
there is in Japan and and they had a hot
spring and so me and my buddy rest in
piece of one of my good friends he we
went in there dude and my buddy was
really good at Yoga and he had one of
them hairless bodies he had a hairless
body and you know I'm polish Nicaraguan
dude so I'm a farmer I'm a farmer at
heart and you know I got at least a
couple of hectares of decent hair around
my body especially around my ass and
hips you know I'm
that hair boy you know I'm that hair I'm
that hair boy I'm that hair boy when I
die they gonna have to braid my legs
before they put me in the casket cuz I
ain't going out like that
you know I'm hair DUP you know I'm
saying my uncle you stuff to gel down
his neck for church cuz he had all hair
on his neck and some people are thinking
a beard nah not a beard okay I know
where a beard goes I'm talking about
follicle DUP around that neck and so
that's you know that's where my family
is at when it comes to all that kind of
stuff but but anyway my buddy was
hairless and he went in there and you
know we went to these natural Hot
Springs and they in Japan and this place
I believe the pronunciation is Kyoto in
Kyoto they had you go in and you pay a
couple dollars you know it might have
been you know four dollars and you get
that you get on they give you these
slippers these magical kind of slippers
and you go in and they got men have been
sitting in these Springs for like a
month
they got one dude in there he was all
pruned up I mean this guy looked like
you know this guy look like about a 90
year old [ __ ] no I'm saying he was
you know kind of damp and kind of pruned
up and then you had a couple of other
business Madhu's in there smoking cigars
but I mean everybody fully naked and
I've never even spent time around the
Japanese you know I mean they had a
rumor that they had a asian kid when I
was young about 17 miles away from where
I grew up and we saved money to go see
him one time in a taxi but he wasn't
there so that was a I don't know that
could have been just a scam or something
they started the taxi company started
just to get people excited about
traveling locally but there was yet we
heard a rumor there was an asian boy and
we went and it wasn't there wasn't one
there was a house somebody built a house
with like a roof kind of crazy on it you
know like this kind of exotic roof but
that was it so we wasted that money that
was about a $60 venture for me and my
two buddies however so back to the story
so we go in this place and never all
that you know they got a lot of Japanese
gentleman in there and everybody's naked
in my buddy he was kind of us he was
kind of a showman you know he was got he
was kind of a showman and he
did yoga and he did he could do it well
so next thing you know my buddies in
this high in this hot spring and
everybody's getting in these pools and
taking these dips and one of them's like
this clay water and stuff and my buddy
in front of like about nine dudes like
gets into on his hands gets like
straight up right like so his legs
straight up in the air and then just
completely does his legs out to the side
and just showed that frickin you know so
that uh you know that little gopher can
and showed that B hole to about nine
Japanese guys and it was I've never seen
anything like it I mean first of all
I've never you know I've never seen
really another man's but I'd seen one
other man's butthole you know and I'll
tell you about that in a second but I'd
never seen I've never seen a group of
guys see it another person's butthole
all at the same time and so that was
kind of the crit that was like kind of
the riveting part because it's one thing
to see somebody see a butthole you know
you can see that on the internet now but
this was seeing a whole flock of men in
a language that I didn't speak you know
and and a lot of time with when you see
someone who speaks a different language
or from a different culture the there's
everything is a little different you
know some of their mannerisms and the
way that they you know behave in the way
and in the face of fear and in the face
of excitement
they're they're instinctual reactions to
things they're they're running off of a
different doll system off of a different
template you know then then you then we
are someone's in other cultures but when
I saw these nine Japanese gentleman you
know catch up you know catch a hit off
my buddies uh off that you know if that
dirty baby wink man it was it was pretty
exotic man I saw say that you know about
six of them bowed kind of did a quick
bow forward one dude looked like he you
know almost like it was a salt like he'd
been waiting for a sign from the heavens
or something and this was it and it
wasn't good
and then they had I think one dude was
blind so he didn't even see it
you know blind if you're blind you don't
know somebody's showing a butthole or if
it's just you know people are just you
know doing small talk you don't know
what's going on really and uh and I
don't remember the other the other the
other guy I don't know he might have I
don't remember but those are the
reactions that I remember you know the
last I don't think he liked it I think
he might have scored it a two but that
was that was uh that was a time that I
went to a hot spring you know that was
my experience with a hot spring there in
Japan you know I did get tickled by a by
a thick boy one time on a cruise ship in
a hot tub and he was I don't want to say
he was on uppers or drugs but it was
because it was early in the morning and
he was only about 12 but if I had ever
had to go to court over that I would I
could not imagine that this boy wasn't
on some ecstasy or something on some you
know children's ecstasy but but look man
if you're taking $24 baths daddy we
don't know each other
okay cuz that's where you bathing you
know that's $3 just even get in the
that's not like a $3 entry fee to a tub
I'm out you know you see you running on
them you running on them high-class you
know you're dipping in this high-class
of waters I mean I you know I'm saying I
pour a couple cups of warm water on your
shoulders for nine bucks but it seem
like you're doing you know you you spend
an extra money that's like one time
somebody put me up at a hotel room I was
doing a show I don't remember where this
was man I think this was in actually in
South Africa and I got booked on this
wild show with this casino and Mark
curry was the headliner hanging with mr.
Cooper
I think Joe coy was on we had a great
group of comedians that were over there
and I was having a blast you know I was
I mean this was an exotic locale and I'm
over there and I'm fired up and then
they said the room was like $600 a night
and I couldn't even go to sleep I'm like
what if I even doze off for an hour
that's 70 bucks
you know so I can imagine if you
spending $24 in a bath you better get
your money's worth
yeah I mean I don't and I don't know how
you do that in a group bath how do you
get your money's worth out of a group
bath that's what you know but the other
time I yeah I forgot the other time I'd
seen some gentlemen's uh you know some
gentlemen's you know dirty little secret
power pot hole was uh was they had this
man in our neighborhood and when he was
young you know he would uh you know I
guess we were younger than him but he
you know from far away man this dude was
kind of wild I guess mr. Garrett but
what he would do was and he might have
been you know honestly he might and I
shouldn't say this cuz I didn't know it
at the time he might have been he might
have had some mental disabilities I
don't know that for sure but he's still
over this family he was getting older
and he wore a book bag all the time
you know and he had kind of a you know
he you know he somebody and his family
cut his hair you know there was some
warrant there were some warning signs
but he would uh he would give you a
couple of dollars two or three dollars
and then he'd walk off about 40 feet and
show you his [ __ ] and the only thing
was you know to make sure you got to
keep that money you at a state Aaron
look and it wasn't you know everybody
these days like everything's pervy and
everything's you know in New York in LA
all these people writing all these
articles and all they're like this is
perverted and this is this and this is
that man [ __ ] wasn't perverted back in
the day you know I was I was at the
Comedy Store last night and Joey Coco
Diaz was saying that Christmas didn't
start until somebody had to dick out and
I'm not saying that I 100% agree with
that and I know he's joking obviously
but people got a quit quit tripping you
know it's just a bunch of people that
are making money off of making all
everything a big deal that's what I hate
about some of these environments because
90% of people don't give a [ __ ]
that's a 90 percent of people do not
care you know you know if you got if you
know there's a big difference between
somebody getting molested and somebody
you see somebody pull her dick out you
can't see a dick what's wrong with you
you came out of a dick somebody show you
their wiener or break at it out
somewhere oh well look the other way
grow up about it I'm so sick of all of
this man and I'm sorry just I know I'm
leaping on this thing but that hey you
know that kind of stuff makes me mad man
and all it is is clickbait it's all
these people just making money man
that's all it is
that's why don't be shocked when you get
you know when people come in when you
get a politician that comes in and just
says whatever he wants everybody's like
[ __ ] yeah I'll listen to anybody who
could say whatever they want
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] because we're so
tired of the other thing people are so
tired of the other thing I'm so tired of
every article everything being somebody
did something wrong somebody said
something wrong somebody hurt somebody's
feelings you know I'm watching these
kids this weekend they had the park land
and you know talking about that
tragedian man there's a great
documentary that's out the NSA great but
it's you know it's about the the Newtown
you know the Newtown tragedy that
happened and I think in Newtown
Connecticut I believe and and I'm
forgiving if I'm saying it wrong I
haven't seen it in a while but it's
really it's uh you know what makes you
feel man if you want those feels you can
go watch that but I'm watching these
children this weekend and hearing some
of them talking it's exciting it's you
know it's exciting to see kids be
empowered it also some of its like like
why where was why aren't like how wire
you know I I agree there's some weapons
they shouldn't have out there
they shouldn't have them I agree
sometimes it do we it'd be great put a
mandate on it we don't really need to
make any get more guns for 10 years
maybe we have a lot of guns also though
like well why you know where were these
kids speaking up when one other
when they when there's a we when there's
a kid at school who's weird or who's
uncomfortable you know when do and I
know that this you know that people had
reported this you know the kid to
parkland kid who had who-who you know
committed the strategy they reported him
you know people were reported this kid
to the FBI I mean the FBI was chasing
you know hunting down you know mythical
servers around the universe that I don't
know whatever happened with that
scenario but obviously they had their
you know they or whatever they were
doing who knows but they didn't you know
it seemed like every protocol was taken
the only protocol that you that we can't
really fix you know they can change the
age of guns sure that you can't buy them
at 18 I think that that's okay you can't
buy an assault rifle at 18 a okay bro
you know I don't think you should be
able to buy gasoline if you're an idiot
I've always thought that oh you're an
idiot we're gonna give you three and you
can buy 300 miles worth of gas that
means now your dumbass can go wherever
you want to [ __ ] that if you're dumb you
can buy gas you get enough gas to get to
school that's it you walk back in that
you're like um you only gave me like a a
mile and a half of the gas and the
attendants like yep that's because the
community colleges and there you go I
don't think you if you're severely
ignorant you shouldn't be able to just
ride around the universe you know
spreading ignorance everywhere but I
wonder where you know where all these
kids speaking up when it's you know when
people are when they will you see that
you got that strange bird in your class
and why does this stuff happen now I
mean I think a lot of it I mean I've
said it before you know I'm not trying
to get too serious but sometimes we got
to talk about things that are topical
you know we got to talk about that stuff
you know and I'm okay to be wrong I
don't know I have no idea
now I never been a parent you know I was
a kid I used to make fun of some kids
sometimes sometimes but not as bad as
some kids did I mean I would joke around
joke around with everybody about the
same you know and I think everybody kind
of got joked around with here and there
but if I saw somebody that I thought was
really getting you know being rude to I
would always step in and try to say
something try to help you know but some
of that stuff's just going to occur but
wait you know some of them just like
what I don't know I just don't sometimes
it just seems like it's all this weird
show that's going on like I'm happy
these kids are motivated and and I'm
happy that yeah they shouldn't have to
be in such fear because it do when you
think about that think about that think
about that think about going to school
now when this stuff starts to happen
every couple months if it does or
whatever year you know if it increases
man I'd be scared to go to school if I'm
already a kid that has a lot of anxiety
I'd be so scared and then the kids who
seem like they are alright you know
uncomfortable at school or the kid who
was you know kind of the odd duck back
in the day now every kid at school was
probably like deaths dudes gonna shoot
up the [ __ ] school cuz that's how
kids are and kids have this thing built
into them you know I just don't know I
don't know I just don't know what some
of it is it's like yeah you have this
show you have this you know these
marches and everything but it's like is
it just yeah I don't know I just don't
see how that solves things but maybe
there is no solution you know maybe some
of it's time I think also we are going
to start to learn like in time like
because you know I grew up in a
generation where we didn't have as much
technology and then we had a too much
technology and I think we're gonna start
to learn how to use technology a little
bit better and how to fit it in with who
we are as humans I hope because it's
definitely it's certainly gotten out of
control I mean you had all these V&O
like you have people's kids so
disconnected to just live in worlds of
video games and you got goober valet
uber cars running over people you got
drones filming the neighbors tits male
or female tits so some things we got a
role
back on now filming them neighbors tots
you know I think those shouldn't I mean
that's kind of okay with me but if you
were taking them $24 baths dude we don't
know each other okay cuz you you takin
their mom you taking those expensive
dips and I don't do that you know I'm
saying you catch me you catch me in a
forty one dollar room at the Ramada
where I can bathe as much as I want and
it's included in that forty one bucks so
I can do whatever I want
I remember once I'm being in a Ramada
they didn't even have a air-conditioned
in that [ __ ] the whole floor was the
third floor was closed because they had
some murder
that's a murder up there and so we were
all down we had a stay second floor or
lower and I remember one of the chip
mile remember first of all they didn't
have air conditioner so we had one of
those little freezers and one of those
little refrigerators in our room and we
just opened the door and we would kind
of sit by that when we got real hot and
let that coolness hit us that little box
you know in those little brown box
frigidaires those little bitty ones and
you just get that you'd open the door
and just get that hit of cold air and
then shut it and wait for it to make
another cold hit or and then I remember
playing hide-and-go-seek and the chip
machine had been all busted out or shot
up somebody had shot it up you know
could have been a brother I mean it
could have been or you know could have
been an aggressive white dude but
somebody has shot up of one of those
frito-lay vending machines or whatever
and somebody hid inside of it dude all
the stuff inside of it was out or had
been broken and somebody hid inside that
Chipman you could just open the door and
get in there and they just in there just
you know kind of trying to be real calm
and look like a you know just look like
a whatchamacallit or something like the
candy you know just trying to stay out
of the way let's cruise to another call
man here we go what happened what's
going on here Casey oh it's Andrea again
this is Andrea from Arizona and I you
know unfortunately I don't know if I
remember the first time you call it
Andrea but thank you for calling back
more
from Arizona but uh I also have another
question like well you have to you gotta
ask a first question before you ask a
second one you know I don't know how
much gasoline you're gonna get let's go
more you know do you like I imagine you
like them all shapes and colors but uh
what type of personality do you like in
a girl you know do you like her to be
funny like you or or docile and quiet
I appreciate you again and by thank you
for calling Andrea I appreciate you as
well
do I like I'm docile I mean I don't like
am under the influence of you know
quaaludes or anything like that you know
I don't want a girl that you have to you
know when you get home you got to take
her out of the trunk and bring her in
the house so I like a girl you know I
don't mind a pigtail I don't I don't
mind two pigtails you know I remember
this one girl only have one pigtail a
month in my neighborhood because they
only had one bar rat at her house and
they got her and her sister got a set of
barrettes for Christmas but the set only
come with two barrettes and so they each
got to use one so they running around
each and look each looking like you know
half a Wendy's logo because each one of
them had that just one you know that one
stray that one braid riding now you know
like I just like a like a diving board
that was you know taking the afternoon
off just kind of hanging off that side
you know gang and out so I don't mind a
little bit of braids I like a
hard-working woman you know I don't want
any of these I don't need I need a
teammate I need a partner in crime you
know I like a woman that knows that life
is hard work I like a woman for me I
think that has some semblance of idea or
thoughts of there being some sort of a
higher power that doesn't have to be
they don't need to believe in Jesus
Christ they don't need to believe in you
know in Mohammed or something a specific
deity or a specific
liaison to a religion but I need them to
you know I want them to believe that
there's something greater out there than
us you know I'm sayin I ain't friggin
backpack ain't carrying around no
atheist I just can't you know because
for me that doesn't work for some people
that may and that's okay if it works for
you but I don't want somebody you know
where every other day feels like
Halloween around the house cuz they dark
art what else do I like you know I dated
a girl with a real small head one time I
wouldn't mind more of like a regular
headed woman I dated a girl had this
little pen top you know at some time
when you were when I was making out with
her I could kiss her and my hands would
touch under her chin and on the top of
her head at the same time and she was an
adult obviously and but I remember just
like Tang she got that little she got
that cabbage ball you know I started
thinking how many how many ideas cuz she
even have in this in this thing in this
hitter you know on top of her neck you
know I was always scared somebody with a
t-ball bat was just gonna roll up and
just you know try to knock a double cuz
she had that look that little baby you
know you know that little that little
you know that little you know mediocre
sphere but she was a beautiful girl I
mean I think she was probably the she
might have been the prettiest girl in
New Orleans but she inch and you know uh
but who knows man to do I like you know
I like a woman that's a hard worker
I like a woman that's a hard worker and
I want a woman that can be a mother you
know I don't want one of these whiny-ass
ladies talking about you know preaching
all the time about you know motherhood
and this and that when they don't have
any children I want a woman who doesn't
mind having some children you know and
who doesn't mind having some children
with me I'm not looking for some
housewife my wife can have a job my wife
can be a CEO my wife can be President of
the United States that's fine with me
but I would hope that if we can have
children that we have them so that's
something
what kind of ladies unlike if I'm just
thinking about being Randy you know I
like
you know I like I mean armor when I was
young I dated you know I like that kind
of native-american looking tight kind of
girl like if you saw her you know if you
walk by and she was wearing a little bit
of you know you know if you peeped in
time if you were peeking in her windows
and she didn't know you were there she
might have had on those you know that
buffalo skin brassiere you know she
might have had a couple of duck uterus
that's kind of woven in with some vine
and holding up her breasts you know just
some lady that's really of the earth you
know that Native American kind of kind
of girl if you peeking in her window at
night you wouldn't be surprised for a
dead frickin drop that arrow right by
year you know part of your hair is wrong
and you know not to look at his daughter
get you know changed clothes and stuff
at night even though you guys are in
love with each other
so I think I had that kind of Pocahontas
sort of thing that I kind of always
maybe envisioned you know and my mother
you know they say that you're attracted
to some characteristics that your mother
has and my mother was kind of uh was
sort of kind of tall dark and handsome I
guess in a way but in a female way my
mother's a hard worker the
hardest-working man I've ever known is
my mother and so I you know I really
admire that you know I need because I
need a teammate and I'm a lot to deal
with I know that you know I'm really
sensitive you know I'm a sensitive
person and I get better at managing my
sensitivity but I still I need
somebody's got that so you know who's
able to follow you know who's able to
deal with that so but also you know I
think it changes over time you know and
you some things I start to see if one
good thing about being you know single
as you get older and being able to kind
of see how relationships shake out and
stuff is that you notice like oh I'm
glad I didn't go with that one I'm glad
I didn't go with that one or I'm you
know I'm not I'm that I didn't go but
I'm glad that when that situation didn't
work out or that situation didn't work
out because of this or because of that
you know you start to see like oh I see
how that how that person goes that way
or how
type of person goes that way you just
get more view so that's one thing that
is kind of rewarding about being single
as I get older it's been able to get a
larger a larger view of what's going on
but you know I you know I've been
fortunate enough to date today some neat
gals you know I hope I haven't in my
life I don't know if I've ever
mistreated any women or done anything
like that you know I think I've been
afraid of commitment and those sorts of
things and so that probably hadn't been
very helpful to some women but but those
are some things that I like you know and
for me of a woman's funny that's
beautiful to me if a woman is if a woman
likes to play board games sometimes in
the evening or in the afternoon then I
like that you know I like a girl that
doesn't mind you know maybe doing like a
silly dance or something or doesn't mind
like you know looking silly sometimes
because those things inspire me you know
I'm always so afraid to like you know
it's kind of weird I'm afraid to look
silly like I'm not afraid to tell jokes
and say things that are silly but I'm
afraid physically sometime to look silly
and so if there's a girl that kind of is
comfortable with those sorts of things
then that makes me feel I you know I
admire that because I wish I could be
that way and then somebody that's
understanding I mean [ __ ] I think I'm
just describing things we all want but
that's some of my ideas Andrea and you
sound like a beautiful young lady and if
I don't have somebody or if you don't
have somebody then at the very least you
know we still treat ourselves with
romance so once you get out there and
put some damn you know put some of that
tzatziki on your thighs you know and
treat yourself right you know light a
candle and pour some wax on your neck or
something you know or dip your shoulders
and chocolate and lick it off do that
side to side
that frickin nervous that'd be that with
that nervous tongue just hunting your
freaking clavicle hunting along your
clavicle with that nervous tongue just
back and forth back and forth
I'm just getting your own chocolate hits
some beauty right there let's hear
another call that came in right here
just kind of chiming into the
conversation here we go oh yeah
kara yeah thank you for calling back
kara because I told you about them
animals you know and I knew I knew a
lady that lived out near Calabasas and
she she had all these show animals you
know she had like the circus mouse from
Green Mile she had the dog from I am
Legend she had the cat from Sabrina the
Teenage Witch
she had a batch of snails from some
famous movie I don't know what it was
and I've never seen their work but on
work you had a little bit more
information about my job and so here it
goes so my job is totally awesome as one
would expect I get to work with all
different kinds of animals every single
day man that's crazy because you
probably get to see animals that the
rest of us don't even know about you
know that's a pretty fascinating I've
always wished that you know that we had
access to all the animals let's hear
more you know I'm probably one of the
few people in this country at least what
absolutely loves their job Wow you know
you sound excited you sound excited
about your job onward so that people
would know that we have done in fact
achill Joker's if anybody has seen that
show which I'm sure many of your
listeners have yep Impractical Jokers
and I went on their cruise two years ago
and I met some great people on there and
my girl Loretta and my boy Kevin out
there and his brother I met them by the
skill crane and they were alcoholics and
we and they now all make all my t-shirts
I met them on the Impractical Jokers
cruise and they're beautiful over there
and they got a brother named Tom who's
taller than them and may or may not have
the same parents
but anyhow yes I've met I dunno the
Impractical Jokers some of them very
special guys and you had an animal that
work with them any animals that you've
seen on that show we have provided all
of them some of my favorite moments and
some of the ones that I can't be seen in
are the episode where Sal is delivering
the cow and also where we put the
tarantulas on cue oh there you go
yeah cue is a sweetheart man you know
there's no if you you want to know about
a group of guys and if you don't know
about them the Impractical Jokers right
and they and they are four of the just
neatest men ever ever and people you
know you might look at them and think
well these guys just made up this silly
show or or this and that but for 20
years they had a group called the
tenderloins and they they they kept
working and they pitched TV shows a
couple of times and almost there and it
didn't happen and almost there and it
didn't happen and then BOOM everything
worked out the way that it was supposed
to and and success couldn't happen to
for better people who have put in the
work who have put in the work but I'm
grateful to know them and that makes me
cool to you that you work with some with
some beautiful show animals that are
obviously humorous if your animals are
providing humor because I'm sure some
people are only doing you know working
with crows are working with Ravens or
vultures you know or Chi or coyotes or
ant what animals that are doing more
violence let's hear more that was doing
that funny things that happen sometimes
the more onset usually if the animal is
having some kind of a bowel movement or
oh this dude is she talking more an
issue onset in that way shape or form
and it's you know rarely rarely you know
somebody's pet dog cat something like
that
okay I'm gonna interrupt this here I
appreciate you calling Kara thank you so
much but I mean this reminds me of a
story they had this man in my town named
IC mite and some people know about this
and I've told her before thing but he
used to have different animals he had uh
I might have told this last week
honestly my brain is so bad you got to
know that about me I don't have a good
memory
and this man you know I see Mike he
would get water from different parts of
America and we were good and he would
freeze it and we would go over his to
his house and eat the ice because a lot
of us you know we didn't travel in my
neighborhood you know you were lucky to
get to Florida once you know by the time
you were 17 so I see Mike you know he
was getting water from you know he was
getting water from Georgia he was
getting water from you know he had a
couple of buckets come down from from
Missouri you know he had a couple of he
had like six gallons or something
somebody you know somebody sold him that
was from Branson I mean this dude was
getting water from some really neat
places and so we he would freeze it and
we would go over there and he would put
it in those ice trays and stuff or just
do a big block he'd put it in those ice
trays and put the toothpicks in it and
after we freed we go over there and eat
it and talk about the area you know and
just fantasize and just be imaginative
about oh well wonder what it was like
you know to you know this water tastes
like maybe they had skiers going through
it or you know maybe they had on like
people having a picnic by the banks or
whatever you know we would just use our
imaginations and think about the ice and
to try and taste different realities
that could have been nearby the water
before it had come to us when it was in
its natural habitat and so anyhow you
know sometime he would get a big you
know he'd just freeze it in a big chunk
and you know it would almost be like a
luau you know we just chip off pieces of
ice and just you know have a little bit
of Lake Mead or you know some I don't
know if he ever got anything foreign you
know but he got some you know I don't
think he ever got any like lake titikaka
or anything like that but you know he'd
have the normal lake pontchartrain or
something from you know Lake Borgne
different stuff but maybe from like
Ontario something like that one time but
anyhow that was good stuff we would have
that well I see Mike he took some acid
one time because a lot of bad LSD would
come through the south and the kind of
[ __ ] were you know the next week
suddenly everybody's you know you know
everybody just kind of like their their
net you know people are wearing vests
I remember or one time everybody bought
a bunch of cowboy boots after some acid
came through see were like ooh you know
that kind of left people a little bit
feeling a little bit country or
different things you know you'd have
people you know some acid would come
through and next thing you know
everybody would be doing artwork in
their yard or something just we you know
[ __ ] where you know the acid was kind of
affecting everybody as a group well I
see Mike got a couple bad hits a couple
of bad squares of that [ __ ] paper
magic and he had this I he quit doing
nice and he put all his money in the
livestock because his daddy had left him
about eight hundred dollars when he died
so he put all his money in a livestock
and he bought a bunch of cattle or large
animals one of them I think was a fat
horse that had a bad you know it had
been somebody kind of scalped it and so
it didn't have like a tail but it looked
like a cowboy
you know what I'm saying similar animals
and he fed them all a bunch of stuff and
he was gonna have him all poop at the
same time and this just goes back to
your story a little bit care about
animal bowel movements but where he was
gonna have them all [ __ ] at the same
time so he sold tickets around town you
know he had you know he could seat about
40 he had some old bleachers out there
so we all going out there to watch the
big [ __ ]
you know everybody's fired up and people
are drinking and everything and some
people even [ __ ] out in the distance
and everybody's waiting for these
animals all the [ __ ] at once and you
thinking to yourself huh that's creepy I
would never watch that but right now
you're still listening to the story and
you're also thinking man I I wonder how
this went so therefore you would watch
that because your brains still hanging
around
isn't it so you know it's come in time
where everybody's expecting you know
8:45 or whatever all these animals are
gonna bust out their asses and
everything at the same time you know
kind of not really a fireworks but you
know something exciting almost a little
bit biblical but then next thing you
know one of the animals got scared you
know because I think a car alarm went
off
for something somebody had a Sun fire
one of the Sun fire cars and basically
if you ever owned a Sun fire I think I
was like a Pontiac Sunbird or Sun fire
the only thing that the car did was the
battery would die and the alarm would go
off I don't even think they were that
you could drive them the battery died
and then the alarm would go off which
was ironic because you needed the
battery to run the alarm but those sun
fires man that's all something one of
those went off anyhow one of these
animals and I don't know what it was it
could have been a you know something
with the deformity it could have been a
[ __ ] it could have been a giraffe
with a you know with Down syndrome I
don't know what you know what was going
on at the time with but one of these
animals took off and people were like oh
[ __ ] this isn't good you know and they
had a man who had been in a war or who
just owned artillery okay and he took oh
he had a grenade a real grenade and you
know sometimes you hear about grenades
and well sometimes you don't well this
is a time when you hear about it
this man threw I don't know if you had a
flashback like somebody was escaped and
this was the enemy or something and I've
never even seen a cow run but this cow
was running if it was a cow and this man
threw a [ __ ] grenade bra and from
looking at this dude
and I know him you know I don't want to
sound won't say his full name but first
name Gary but spelled ger ry so I'll
give those clues if somebody from my
town is listening and some people call
him mr. Gary and I never called him that
but anyhow Gary throw this grenade and
I'm thinking no way Gary's gonna he
don't look like a man that's very
accurate and I'll be damned boy if Gary
couldn't [ __ ] start a barbecue from
300 feet away with a damn grenade
fascinating so you know not cool and I'm
not the kind of guy who glorifies that
kind of stuff I don't think animal
cruelty is good this is before they had
animal cruelty this is 20 years ago when
animals and humans were still fighting
each other a lot and not seeing eye to
eye but that [ __ ] went off boy and so
that's why I'm
from if you learn oh where I'm from
that's where I'm from so don't people
act like are you from here that's where
I'm from all right but thank you for
calling young lady and I'm sorry to get
fired up let's hear another call hey my
name is Avery and I am a open mic
comedian out of Detroit
Avery Detroit man and thank you for
calling dude and God bless you guys man
I know that you know G I can't even
imagine where your state has been
through in the past 20 years you know I
know it's probably been tough up there
in Michigan and people having a tough
time and this and that and you guys are
powerful and you guys persevere and and
keep your head up you know keep your
head up just you know I just can't
imagine you know when you have an
industry in your city or in your
neighborhood or in your town and your
grandparents worked in it and maybe your
father worked in it and suddenly that
industry is disappearing you don't know
what to do and people don't know what to
do you know and then next thing you know
everybody's yelling at you because
you're not living your life right what
do you want me to do I've got three kids
you know and I live in this town already
I can't just up and move to some you
know so I don't know I didn't mean to
get all into that [ __ ] but but thank you
for calling man oh we're doing about a
year now just start now love listen to
the podcast love the motivation if you
tried to improve your life and I heard
your comments recently about
masturbation and I have some thoughts
out of it well thank you for calling
Avery out and I do I you know I do do
masturbation and I am I'm trying to get
I'm trying homework and actually do a
little bit of a bit about it cuz I I
don't know whether masturbation is good
or bad because in the Bible it's just as
bad and that you're not supposed to do
it but everybody says that it's not a
big deal but my thought is is that the
Bible is right about masturbation and
that is bad because it's not about the
devil or anything like that it's bad
because it satisfies you so like if
you're if you're feeling bad and you
want to feel good you either have the
option to go out and make your life
better by doing the hard stuff or you
can just rub your dick can feel good
right away that's true and that's you
know and I've chosen that path many
times probably 20 or 30 20 15 thousand
times rubbing my dick I mean like
there's a damn genie in there and you're
right you know we we put these things in
for I do I'm not gonna say we and I
don't know you but you know you're
sharing some of this stuff I put things
in my way
do anything anything I can put in my way
to prevent me from having to deal with
myself and make myself a better person
or to get better I will do it it could
be a cigarette
it could be masturbation it could be
looking at pornography it could be you
know doing some mild people in Thailand
from far away but safe distances and I
don't do that anymore
I don't even think I'm out there like
that but you know over time and I look
back in my life anything I could do
instead of having to sit there and be
with myself
anything I could do and some people say
you're so Restless yeah I was Restless
but I also I didn't want to I was afraid
you know I didn't want to wrestle with
what was really making me feel you know
I didn't want to wrestle with you know
why do you want to go you know do
something why do you want to act out
right now why do you want to go jerk off
or you know smoke us say or do something
you know or why do you want to why do
you why do you have to go eyes nothing
why are you not okay right now and I
didn't want to answer that question why
am I not okay I didn't want to answer
that instead I just wanted to find
something else to do so that I could
keep putting that question off but now
I'm gonna point in my life or I choose
to try and answer it and I don't have
the answer but you know more shall be
revealed I find the the more effort
sauce even if they're little efforts I
make to treat myself better and to take
care of myself more is constantly
revealed constantly and I never thought
that would be possible but thank you for
calling Avery and good luck out there
and it does it weakens you you know
because I used to do this I used to I
would meet a girl if I liked her
and instead I would just I would get
scared to go meet up with there and just
anxiety off and the next thing you know
I would text her call her and cancel the
date and then I would I'd be so tired
from jerking off or whatever because I
do big jerks I'd be so tired from doing
those big jerks that I would be too
exhausted even go out or doing anything
and so now I'm just alone by myself and
then that being alone starts to you know
and I said this last week I think it's
like a moss it's like a dart it's like a
moss that grows in the dark the more you
stay inside and the more you be alone
that that grows on itself this is real
information you can go look at this [ __ ]
or you can just if you're living this
you can ask yourself and you'll feel
that it's true and I'm not accusing
anybody or I mean but I've been there I
spent probably eight years running in
that same circle just not taking care of
myself and then feeling bad for not
taking care of myself and back and forth
just like it was a notion like that ty
we go in and the ty we go out and I
wouldn't take care of myself and then
I'd feel bad for not taking care of
myself and that was it that was my life
but not anymore boy not anymore
all right we're gonna get into a couple
calls here that you know we have the
contest every month that we just started
this is our first month where we give
away one of those Correctional Center
blue this past weekend t-shirts and I'll
put one up tonight on the this past
weekend Instagram and if you're not
following that feed you can follow it at
this past weekend underscore I believe
it is and and whoever calls in you got
to hit the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three and you
have to leave a message it needs to be
60 seconds or less tell me about your
weekend and why it was great or why it
was horrible now don't call in every
week call him when you have a good one
because we got a whole box that he's
Correctional Center blue shirts we gonna
send him out and they got her they got
her dude I wouldn't put a ugly baby in
one of these things but you know I
wouldn't start a [ __ ] fire with one
of them if I was gonna kill myself in my
garage
by starting up a car and putting
something in the gas in the gas in the
tailpipe
I would use this shirt but we're gonna
give us if we're gonna give one I'm away
the Z it isn't coming in on the end of
the first month and we got a couple of
final contestants here that called in
here we go
hey Theo this is max only share my
passion with you thanks for calling max
and I have a nephew named Maximus and
he's a he's a special kid homeward me
and three my buddies we did the magic
mushrooms
oh boy y'all got that fungus in your
frikken and yeah burn go you let's hear
for we were watching Finding Nemo damn
boy - they got homoerotic in a
[ __ ] bruh you know and maybe
everything just gets gay to me dude
that's maybe that's maybe I have
something going on I'll work on the
PlayStation 3 PlayStation 3 has a button
on it that uh it's called like repeat
the scene button so it repeats like a
five minute scene over and over well um
I'm tripping on the mushrooms I
accidentally stepped on a remote hit the
repeat theme button wow I can already
see where this is going man but I want
to hear you tell me so after you know
about watching the same 5 minute scene
probably 15 times we all are tripping
and being like dude we just watched a 2
hour movie probably you know like 15 20
times like you must have been down here
for like two three days so we all
thought we were down there for days on
watching Finding Nemo we thought we
stayed up for like maybe three days
straight watching Finding Nemo that's
heavy man and that sounds like honestly
a place where a couple dudes would end
up [ __ ] to be honest with you and
guys who don't usually [ __ ] but would
and I'm not accusing you guys are saying
anything but you know when you got three
dudes why and suddenly you know people
forget the movies still going and your
next thing you know it's two days later
and everybody comes up out of the
basement you know someone
gonna be smelling like ass usually but
thank you for calling man and I'm glad
you guys had fun on those mushrooms but
you got to get outdoors in the future
unless you guys are in cold weather
somebody could die out there on
mushrooms because mushrooms will warm
your body up you think you're warm and
next thing you know you die of it of uh
whatever it is impose EEMA or something
from being in the snow thank you for
calling though and that was a that was
an interesting weekend let's hear one
more right here
hey Theo this is Andrew from Deadwood
South Dakota and a lot of people know
what dead end would mean separately but
Deadwood is a place where old Cowboys
used to get shot anyway they have a big
party every st. Patty's Day and my
brother came down from college this past
weekend we went gambling and play my
partying and drinking no drug in but it
was really good cuz I hadn't seen him in
a while oh that's nice I'm glad you guys
spent some time there with your with
your sibling more we got out during the
day with a beautiful day on Friday
and we went rock climbing in that damn
y'all active y'all Brotherhood is really
active my brother knob we barely get
over to the pizza hut more and then it
snowed a ton on Saturday and we damn and
this just starting to lead to romance
too you notice how a lot of these boys
things be leading a row man let's hear
more thank you to go up snowboarding
Deadwood's up in the mountains of South
Dakota and so it's a really good time
and I really enjoyed seeing my brother
my dog just died and so I've been you
know kind of lonely I moved here by
myself and so it was a really really
special weekend just to kind of grow it
up and see him so oh man I appreciate
you calling the saying that dude that's
nice
I'm glad you and your brother got to
spend some time together man you know
it's uh but it sound like you made the
most of it you know and that's something
I want to do more in my life is just you
know I want to try and make the most of
this time because I get caught up same
habits you know okay well let's just
stay in and watch tube or less you know
uh you know I'll just eat the same
anything on us have this same macaronis
you know I'll just have it you know I'll
just get a pair and just cut this pair
up and have to have another pair but
sometimes you know you've got to be
adventurous and you got to get up early
and take that a take and you got to make
your life you got to add spice to it you
know when it doesn't you got to add I
mean I hate to say it man but you got to
go back to that romance you got to go
back to that romance you know you that's
all like that's what it is you got to
add that romance to your life and it
doesn't even have to be in a sensual way
or in anything but you and your brother
you decided to make you put some some
type of a feeling in your day you know
some type of an action some type of a
you went you know you guys went rock
climbing you went snowboarding Jesus man
if my brother and I wouldn't do that one
of our [ __ ] legs would fall off but
you made it you know you got a you got
active and that is uh that's the kind of
thing that will keep us out of the dark
arts is staying active because otherwise
you out there like me and Avery out
there in Detroit jerking off and
wondering you know how Eminem just seems
so different than he did 20 years ago I
mean you just don't know it's wow man
but you you be you out there you're
making your life you're adding rural
mass to your life and I appreciate that
Andrea I appreciate you calling it sound
like a great weekend you had
so those are two weekends that came in
and those will be uh there's a
contestants and I already I know the
winner right here and I'm gonna play it
for you right now you heard it before
but here it is APO this is Nate from
Massachusetts just calling us share the
best weekend I had in a long long time I
got to spend a beautiful sunny late
winter Saturday out on the ice fishing
with my six-year-old son and both of his
granddaddy's you know by the time I was
old enough to remember him half my
grandparents have passed on and by then
the other half maybe didn't have time to
go out and spend a whole day out in the
ice with a little youngster there you go
and that's going to be it man there was
more to that call but I'm gonna shut it
down there that's Nate Nate's gonna get
that
blugh Correctional Center blue hitter
and we'll send that to you Nate will hit
you up over text and thank you for that
call man I'm glad you and your boys got
to get out there on that frozen tundra
because a lot of people when they the
story is you hear when people go out
onto the ice with senior citizens you
know it's like a lot of Italians [ __ ]
you know somebody gets gunned down
that's mafioso style so to know that you
guys are in a family atmosphere out
there enjoying one another's company you
know no big debts to pay off and nobody
you know getting revenge or anything for
a previous issue or you know something
you know some super Italian activity and
beautiful so Nate you got that
Correctional Center blue header we'll
send that to you last week on the last
episode I talked about you know going
that they're being struggling with
whether or not I want to go to my
therapist oh I got to tell you this too
my boy last last week we talked about he
sent me these candles you know and I got
him lit right in here and these are root
beer and it's a nice man dude it's the
candle man he said he sent me this note
and I couldn't open him last week
because the packaging was just too much
stuff and I was gonna get all over all
the little shards of paper and just
thing like that but he sent me these man
and I'm gonna put it I'm gonna put a
link to him I just really appreciate it
they're nice candles and candle make me
relax man it's crazy if you're a big
fire a big fire will make you get your
laptop get your animal get out the house
you know get your baby book or whatever
and get it you know get a couple thing
of jewelry and get out the house but a
little candle a little fire make you
feel comfortable so really a lot of our
comfort in life comes is based on how
much fire is around I noticed that but
yeah he has on some beautiful candles
right now I'm gonna put a link to them
below joey Piemonte
handmade up cycled container candles and
I'll put a link to his he have a epsy
shot in a Facebook page but it's a
hangover candle and you can check them
out at hangover a candle and they're
nice and I appreciate that nice gift man
helps me feel relaxed here in the new
studio here we go I go to therapy and a
son I feel like not going
and I feel like not going we talked
about it last week or I did that I just
don't you know I get that thing it's
like you don't need to go you don't need
to go this is it you know this ain't
helping you anymore you know this ain't
helping you anymore okay and we got this
call right here on that topic
hi so I've called you before and I had
some advice for you like when you feel
like you don't want to go there you
don't want to go see your therapist
generally there's what I do I say I
don't want to talk about it
that's generally why I don't want to go
fear yeah that's true that's what I yeah
I don't want God well my brain will say
oh you're too busy you got too much
going on you don't have time those sorts
of things will be some of the excuses
that we're coming to my head but let's
hear more and then I ask myself
what don't you want to talk about and
did I do not amen
that's a good that's a great it's a
great little you know for some it's a
great that's a great little thing that
could help you you're thinking about not
going with everything why don't I want
to go what don't I want to talk about I
can answer for you what don't I want to
talk about with my therapist I don't
want to talk about that I don't like her
sometimes sometimes she makes me feel
uncomfortable you know but it's so it's
such few moments that to them to compare
to the weight of the times that I've
felt helped that it's it's it doesn't
even compare but that's one thing that
could pop into my head and that will
sometimes what else I don't want to talk
about you know that I'm afraid of of
commitment you know I don't want to talk
about the fact that you know I'm afraid
to get married and have a family because
you know I might ruin it you know I
don't want to talk about you know the
fact that I feel sometimes that by
living in Los Angeles you know that I'm
like letting my family down because they
don't get to see me
very much and it's crazy because the
same things that they know what brought
me out here sometimes in the beginning
or made me want to chase some of these
dreams I have was feeling like nobody
there was nothing holding me back
because I didn't have any real family
and then now my family's changed so much
over the years that now I feel that you
know I'm that now I'm you know letting
them down by being here you know and I
know some of that's not true but it's
still you know or or just that I'm you
know not taking advantage of what's most
important so those are some things yeah
maybe I don't you know that I don't want
to talk about water so why wouldn't I
want to go because I wouldn't want to
say those things I wouldn't want to tell
somebody that you know I wouldn't want
to tell somebody that you know that part
of me is worried that I'll be alone
forever but not because somebody won't
love me or won't care about me but
because I won't let them you know that I
won't really do the work to let them but
thank you for your call let's hear
another call or two that came in real
quick here we go yo she boy well from
he's in Texas Royale
thank you for calling there's a king of
all YouTube from Jackyl woo it's called
good Jocko Willick yes tell me more and
there's a lot to read and it says if you
can say the word good that's what it
means you're still alive it means you're
still breathing
and if you're still breathing well
they'll tell you still got some fight
left in you so get up don't stop reload
we told them we engage and go out on the
Atlanta yo wow boy well from using there
you go and he said right there that if
you can say the word good then you got
some fight left in you you know that's a
nice monocore to to go
it's you need to get out there and go
out on the attack and I do believe that
we if you want this world if you want
this [ __ ] you got to stay on it you got
it you have to stay on it you have to
have your plan and you got to work
toward you you got to move forward and
you can let yourself go here and there
you can let yourself down sometimes but
we need to have a plan long term to keep
ourselves up and if you can't find it
then ask somebody who has one it's
amazing how much people are willing to
help other people I will never ever be
surprised by by the kindness in humans
never be surprised man like old Blanche
what's-her-name said in a streetcar
named desire I've always depended upon
the kindness of strangers and I that's
true for me as well thank you for
calling around well here we go got a
this call came in this fellow looking
for some suggestions and guidance here
we go yo what up Co with your boy Chris
Jones in Atlanta what's up Chris Jones
and they had a boy when I grew up named
Chris Jones named Toby his nickname was
Toby you know like a piece of your foot
but different and uh and he was always
kind of a nice and wild kid and he lived
in my area you know he kind of had that
day and he had a little bit of danger in
him you know he had that squirrel he
almost he always had like a [ __ ] you
know kind of a squirrel living in his
neck a little bit he was ready to go you
know more I was callin I was just
thinking because I just had my wife and
I had our first son congratulations
brother thank you thank Jones and had
him on March 19th which is your birthday
I know which Saint Jones and had them on
March 19th which is your birthday I know
that's my birthday man I appreciate it
I'm happy to share with your boy and
we're not leave this when I leave this
earth you'll probably still be around to
carry it on
so appreciate you sharing that more
which super awesome as far as I'm
concerned had the same birthday Steve on
well I'll tell you this we both have the
same birthday as dr. Seuss
and his name is Theodore Geisel and he
was born on March 19th
so I think that's somebody that's way
more interesting but that's pretty cool
as well as well as your boy more but
anyway my question is before that I had
a daughter and a wife and ever since we
came home with the boy now it's kind of
even the penis to vagina ratio in the
house mm-hmm and there's been nothing
outward but I feel that silently there's
been a turning of the attitude on the
female part well yeah yeah man cuz they
see they they got mo [ __ ] and in the
kennel you know I'm saying if you [ __ ]
up a kennel bra
you know then Virg it is gonna they're
gonna they gonna get wild they're gonna
get scared and that's normal man that's
nature you know a lot of times we don't
realize and I'm not saying you don't
realize but a lot of times we have to
remember that nature's do another that
we're just little pieces of nature you
know we're just pawns and rooks and we
might think we're kings and queens but
we're pawns and rooks and Mother Nature
have this bigger thing going on mother
nature could sent a meat-eor and it's a
wrap
okay I don't care how many Instagram
followers we got or how many new dodge
caravans we own or our leasing it's a
wrap
and you know somebody was telling me the
other the other day and this could just
be hearsay I don't know but somebody was
telling me that if there is a that when
when things start to get kind of wild in
the universe that more women will be
born when there's more stress in an area
or in a country that more females will
be born and that's that's crazy man
because if you know the world needs and
knows that it needs more motherhood and
more pacifist and it needs more that
ability to understand I think that is
innately built into a woman or
most women now there's some American
women out here that are trying to really
test that [ __ ] that are trying to go
against mother nature and I don't know
how that's gonna work sometimes in the
end but I think that there's uh you know
Mother Nature has a plan you know we got
to believe that I think and that's
probably all that's going on you got
over there you know it's just like
father time and mother nature just
moving their rooks and pawns around and
they just add another little rook to
your game set over there let's hear
another call there but I appreciate well
we get a question let me hear what the
question is and I'm wondering if you
ever had any experience with that the
thing where you know the girls are
outnumbered and they put out a different
vibe but then once you know you kind of
even up that pain to the gene race no
I've never I don't know much about that
I do I did hear though that if a lot of
girls ride together on a bus or
something for a long distance that
they're all their periods will line up
and they will do that you know kind of
kind of sort of the same thing that I
see Mike was trying to put on you know
they were trying to put that big that
big view Latian you know they trying to
you know put that big ovulation at one
point you know this that big outgoing
tide all of a sudden at one point so I
heard that if girls ride like a couple
hours on a I don't wanna say a school
bus or a greyhound yeah not a school bus
because we're talking about adults but
on a greyhound or on a bus then they
will all have the same period clock
period schedule but thank you for
calling man I wish I knew more
here we go Pat yeah what's up my name is
Pat I'm from Cleveland I'm 34 I started
with this past weekend probably four
weeks ago I listen to all the monopolist
know I just fell pretty big fan Thank
You Pat and John we're tez from from
this is us is on the allegedly episode
that's on right now I'll put up a
picture that I'm Instagram to remind
people thank you for calling Pat you
sound down in the dumps bro Z what's up
I got a question I'm a painter I got a
couple of kids
and the ones and
been pretty rough the past I'd take two
months I just bought a house and you
know might have been a little out of
reach for me just had to borrow money
for my father
anyways I really frickin hate my job
mmm so it sound like you definitely have
some add some new stress going on man
I'm sorry to hear that
you know I know that's a big that's a
scary moment and you get something new
and you had that new lease milling about
you got the family to that's a that is a
fixed cost at this point because you
can't I mean that's a fixed cost
emotionally and fiscally because you
can't adjust that you had to borrow some
money for your father I'm sure that that
can be I don't know y'all relationship
but that can it might come with some
extra feelings of weakness or
inferiority that may accompany that move
depending upon your relationship with
your dad
onward and like I said I'm 34 and I'm
not sure what I even want to do and how
to go back to college even or even if
I'm smart enough or whatever I know it's
something like a [ __ ] right now but uh
this okay man we all [ __ ] breath more
just looking for any advice on kind of
just trying to start over and be able to
you know support my family at the same
time well you know I don't have a lot of
suggestions in that world and some other
people might you know and they can hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three about starting over
and about switching moves and you know I
think a little bit you're gonna maybe
hate to hear this but it sounds like and
I you know I don't even know if I could
do it but it sounds like you know I mean
you got a man up you got a man up you
know yeah you could I mean you certainly
look you could take some classes and try
to ease into school try a night course
or try a you know try a class here and
there you can do that you know that's
highly pop that's highly plausible but I
mean first and foremost you know you
have to make sure you have income coming
in you know you have to create a
schedule you're going to be paying your
stepdad back even if are your
father back even if it's you know a
little bit or whatever you're you know
you got it you want to stick to that
schedule so that that doesn't get weird
you know you want to keep that family
thing in line at first and then if you
can add another you know another log to
the fire you know to see if you can
start a new to burn in a new direction
then that then you can do that well you
can I mean it's gonna take some extra I
hate to say it man you don't want to
hear it but it's gonna take some extra
work but in the meantime look I I
commend you
you know like I'm 37 dude I don't have a
family you know I mean you tell me you
know you got a family and that makes me
feel that makes me feel envious you know
you come home and you got people you
know you got something with little arms
that runs up to you that's not a gremlin
and it wants to hug you and that to me
that's beautiful so you have some really
cool gifts it seems like you know you
get to paint man you get to paint I
don't you know I don't know if you're
damn Picasso or your [ __ ] pd's paint
service I don't know which one you are
but you know I I love my job people say
that all the time but it is a job in the
end this is a job man I mean podcasting
has been something different this is
different but but going to comedy it's a
job it was great when I started and
there's still a lot of fun and there's a
lot of times where I really enjoy it but
you still have to get up and go there
you know you still have to fly to Nevada
or wherever or you know a different
state some other place and you got to do
it you still got to do your job I still
have to do that you know so work is work
it is what it is you know in a few years
your industry might change you don't
know what the next thing is you know if
you you never know whose house you might
be painting one day and then they bring
you they notice your work ethic or your
attitude and they bring you into the
fold with something amazing that they're
doing I'm gonna tell you this man I uh
when I've been doing comedy about eight
years I was real scared and I was kind
of in love with this girl
in Louisiana and so I went back there
for about six months and I had to get a
job and I got a job at a taco place this
place was making kind of decent tacos
you know medium meat not upscale you
know not them upscale hitters but medium
hitters and I had to bartend I was
Barton I never bartending anything but
they had a smoothie machine that sold
that had alcoholic smoothies margaritas
that's what their that's what they were
and I would just make those and slang
these you know tacos to people and one
night I'm sitting there I'm washing
glasses and I was you know at the same
time at the same time I had comedy that
was on Comedy Central that it just
popped off you know but that but that
wasn't paying my bills I wasn't taking
care of me so here I was back in
Louisiana you know and I'm renting a
house with my sister and they got
strippers coming over and stealing the
vacuums and [ __ ] and we and I'm out here
and there's a man sitting there one
night and he starts telling about this
piece of property and next thing you
know man's fast forward four months I
owned one of the hottest pieces of
property in Louisiana now I got into a
weird scenario with some friends and you
know I didn't really make the best
choices and you know it was you know you
shouldn't do business with friends
sometimes and and I lost the the the
property right and but I dude by being
there and sitting there and washing
those glasses and showing up to work and
just being taking on some humility
dude I'm sitting I was on television
which I know it doesn't mean anything to
a lot of people and that's fine but to
be sitting there you're on TV and you
the [ __ ] you know you're washing
people's glasses and [ __ ] that's life
that's [ __ ] life you know and to be
able to do that and and then that's when
something beautiful we can come along
you know and I still have to remind
myself of that all the time is that you
know if every day I got to find some way
to humble myself and there just to do my
job but yeah man you know you know if
you show up and you know it's hell your
perspective you're in a tough spot you
got a lot going on
so I would just take care of yourself
right now make sure you get some rest
when you can I would make sure you're
eating I will make sure you're doing
something athletic a little bit even if
it's trying to do a little jog or
something to keep your blood flowing and
keep your your your spirit happy and
keep your heart healthy and and if you
can try to just adjust your perspective
then maybe what you have going on right
now might be everything you want because
to me dude honestly in some ways you
sound like a rich dude you know you know
what I used to love to sweep the porch
man when I was growing up man I hated
where we lived you know I hated I hated
feeling poor I hated all the shame that
I came that I felt every day when I woke
up but one thing I love to do is sweep
the porch good when that thing was done
boy that thing was done and I worked on
a farm house over there in Natchez
Mississippi outside of there near
Vidalia over near off of the levee and I
used to and then they let me paint the
farmhouse one summer a man I felt
achievement so you know we all have a
little things and maybe you know you
won't paint forever but right now try
and just you know if you show up to
paint now you're fired up about it the
brush gonna be lighter the cut the color
is gonna be brighter you know and when
somebody you know you never know who
you're gonna pass across things changed
a lot and change can be waiting for you
but you got to put yourself in a
position you know you might not have to
take that class you might not have to go
back to school you know or you might but
you know you get a little bit lighter in
your brain I bet that you are going to
get you can have more room inside of
yourself for clarity for what could best
occur and of course I do not know man I
don't know anything but that's something
that I would maybe try you know all
right one more thing here and then we'll
be done man here we go you're gonna drop
a clip on the YouTube channel when you
hit that
thirty thousand subscribers and about
thirty-one now so you know you own the
game
you're right Jesse I do and you know
what I tried to record it over there in
Tacoma and I got a look at the tapes I
haven't had an opportunity yet but I
promised YouTube followers when we got
to thirty thousand that I will put the
clip up and Jesse I appreciate you
holding me accountable to that and I
will do it out if this if the clip is
good because I do wanted to put it up in
a format where it's you know best serves
the material so I'm gonna try to get
that up if it's if the tapes that I got
over there and Tacoma were good then
I'll get this up and if not then I will
get it up really really soon
I appreciate that call Jesse as always
you know you can hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three if you have any thoughts or
suggestions or anything like that you
know this this this shows gonna change
all the time you know we don't know what
it is sometimes and we're still figuring
it out and I'm hoping to have a guest
coming up soon and what else
that's an email on the way out man I'm
gonna play this again this is by Jamison
flood and I appreciate you guys being
here with me tonight take care of
yourselves we may have a Thursday
episode it depends trying to get this
guest in if not it I know you guys have
Easter this is Easter week you know
heading in a good Friday and you know
try and celebrate trying you know every
you know life can be heavy sometimes but
we have the option of of how much we
want to feel the weight you know
sometimes we have a little bit of room
there where we can just not feel it so
much you know but find some romanticism
your life this week whether you got to
tell yourself you love you whether you
got to tell your higher power that you
love them you know whether you got a hug
a kid or [ __ ] whether you got to
paint you know less [ __ ] on the side of
somebody's house
whatever you got to do like my boy Pat
out there but thank you guys for your
support
let's keep keep it romantic let's keep
it romantic huh and I'll see you guys
either Thursday I'll see you next Monday
you guys be good to your cells this is
Jameson flood with every night
[Music]
every
[Applause]
[Music]